this story National Security Advisor
Michael Flynn resigned last night and we
are just a couple of weeks into this
administration you know and people are
now questioning what did President Trump
know when did he know it is this
something that is that particular angle
have any legs is that gonna be a story
or I think so and it is four weeks in
it's pretty early to be saying what did
the president know and when did he know
it right and why didn't he disclose it
to the American people when he knew as
they're saying two weeks ago he was
informed is that yeah and on Friday he
was asked about it about a report in The
Washington Post whether this was made
public that general Flynn had in fact
talked about sanctions with the Russian
ambassador when during the Obama
administration and said we'll revisit
the these sanctions later don't worry
about it and then gone and lied about it
and then mr. Trump President Trump was
asked about it on Friday and he said oh
I hadn't seen that report I don't know
what you're talking about I'll look into
it when obviously he's known about it
okay so usually we get into the what did
the president know and when did he know
it two years into the second term yeah
not four weeks right
four weeks is a little early you know
he's doing things differently
you